these days movie fans are constantly
bombarded with trailers posters and new
information about all kinds of tentpole
franchise films on the flip side however
there are a few upcoming movies that
have managed to fly under the radar from
sci-fi epics to action-packed thrillers
here are some of the sequels you might
not know are being made after years of
speculation that a fourth Matrix film
was in the works variety broke the news
in August 20 19 that a new installment
in the series was indeed on the horizon
and that despite previous rumors
it wouldn't be following a new character
after all original stars Keanu Reeves
and carrie-anne moss will be returning
for the matrix for along with original
writer and director lana wachowski
and while wachowski may have partnered
with her sister Lily to make the first
three Matrix movies the fourth
installment will have only the one which
house key at the helm in addition to
which house key the script for the
matrix four will be co-written by
Alexander Hammond and David Mitchell and
is set to start production in early 2020
no plot details have yet been revealed
for the movie and it isn't yet clear how
the film plans to incorporate moss or
Reeves characters who were killed in the
third film in the franchise The Matrix
Revolutions it is equally unclear
whether Laurence Fishburne's character
Morpheus will be making an appearance
some sources have speculated that he may
be recast in order to appear as a
younger version of the character but
that remains speculation for now James
Cameron has been talking about his
avatar sequels almost from the moment
the first film exploded on two screens
in 2009 smashing box-office records and
eventually becoming the highest-grossing
film of all time
however despite years of Cameron's
repeated promises of a vast and
expansive avatar franchise it was
beginning to feel as though a follow-up
was as far off and unreachable as the
moon of pantora itself but believe it or
not for more avatars really do appear to
be imminent in fact according to
Sigourney Weaver the first two have
already finished shooting
they've even got titles avatar the way
of water avatar the seed bearer avatar
the token rider and avatar the quest for
a WA what does it all mean well no one
knows except James Cameron himself and
his eclectic cast which in addition to
the original movie stars also features a
host of newcomers including Edie Falco
Kate Winslet Michelle Yeoh Jemaine
Clement and Vin Diesel everyone else
will have to wait until the end of 2021
to find out avatar the way of water is
scheduled for release on December 17
2021 with avatar the seed bearer
arriving on December 22nd 2023 avatar
the Tolkien writer following on December
19th 2025 and avatar the quest for a WA
concluding the franchise on December
17th 2027 as the crew of the Nostromo
learned the hard way all the way back in
1979 it's pretty hard to kill an alien
and the Alien franchise seems just as
tough as the creature itself reflecting
on his landmark sci-fi horror film on
its
fortieth anniversary director Ridley
Scott told variety that a third prequel
is indeed on the way intended as a
follow-up to 2012's prometheus and 2017
alien covenant
despite generally positive critical
reviews covenant underperformed at the
box office
throwing the future of the franchise
into uncertainty but following Disney's
acquisition of Fox both Scott and aliens
new studio homes seem eager to return to
the sinister stars yet again as for what
this third prequel might be about only
one thing is for sure it won't follow
the format of the original alien
speaking to The Hollywood Reporter Scott
talked about the need for the franchise
to continue to evolve in order to
succeed he said you can't keep repeating
the same premise because the joke gets
boring
the next alien film tentatively titled
alien awakening is still in the very
early stages and none of the cast of
Covenant has yet been asked to return
still Scott maintains three things it's
happening he'll be directing it and it's
currently in the script phase after the
release of the poorly received Indiana
Jones and the Kingdom of the Crystal
Skull no one would have blamed Harrison
Ford Steven Spielberg and everyone else
at Lucasfilm if they'd given up on the
Indiana Jones franchise altogether but
now it appears that India will be back
with Indiana Jones 5 which despite a
number of push backs and delays is still
theoretically happening Indiana Jones 5
has gone through a number of
screenwriters already from Crystal Skull
scribe David Koepp two solos Jonathan
Kasdan - this is us creator Dan Fogelman
and now apparently back to kept no word
has yet been given on what Indiana Jones
5 will be about although Harrison Ford
will be at least 78 when the movie
starts filming so chances are that the
adventure will have to be a little less
physically rigorous than previous
installments
[Music]
it's the mileage of course it's possible
that even the filmmakers don't quite
know the movie's plot yet speaking to
den of geek in September of 2019 kept
said I'm working on it again we're still
trying and I think we've got a good idea
this time we'll see if Indiana Jones 5
is indeed still hanging around in the
good idea stage it's probably got a long
way to go before it actually hits
theaters still according to everyone
involved it'll get there eventually bill
may have finally been killed at the end
of 2004 is Kill Bill Vol - but that
hasn't stopped director Quentin
Tarantino from expressing his desire for
another sequel to round out the trilogy
according to Tarantino the third kill
bill would focus on the daughter of
Vernita green who is now all grown up
and on the hunt for revenge against the
person who killed her mother uma
thurman's Beatrix Tarantino has said
that he's had talks with Thurman about
Kill Bill Vol 3 as recently as July of
2019 telling MTV if any of my movies
were going to spring from my other
movies it would be a third kill bill of
course a third kill bill may throw a
wrench in Tarantino's plans to retire
after his tenth film his ninth Once Upon
a Time in Hollywood hit theaters in the
summer of 2019 and his tenth an upcoming
Star Trek film is currently in the works
then again no one but Tarantino himself
is going to hold him to a self-imposed
film cap if he chooses to keep going
nothing is finalized for a Kill Bill
sequel yet but it seems as though all
that would be needed for it to
materialize is simply for Tarantino to
decide to pull the trigger
although rumor has it that a third
Sherlock Holmes film has always been
part of the plan over at Warner Brothers
Robert Downey jr. has spent the past
decade leading the Marvel Cinematic
Universe as the genius billionaire
playboy philanthropist Tony Stark saving
the world every couple years is
obviously a pretty draining gig and
Downey's superhero commitments kept him
from being able to take up Sherlock's
trademark deerstalker and pipe for a
third time but now that Downey has
seemingly exited the MCU for good he
finally has the time to team up with
Watson
solve one more case and take his last
bow as the famous detective
the third Sherlock Holmes film will be
helmed by Rocket Man director Dexter
Fletcher a departure from the first two
films which were both directed by Guy
Ritchie while Sherlock Holmes 3 was
originally scheduled to release on
Christmas Day 2020 it has since been
pushed back a year and will now be
striking into theaters in December 2021
the hit man's bodyguard wasn't exactly a
critical success earning a pretty lousy
rotten tomato score but the movie did
pretty well at the box office
pulling in almost one hundred and
seventy seven million dollars worldwide
against a 30 million dollar budget after
all how can an audience possibly say no
to the combined charisma of Ryan
Reynolds and samuel l.jackson well fans
of the first film will be happy to know
that the hit man's bodyguard is getting
a sequel confusingly titled the hit
man's wife's bodyguard Reynolds and
Jackson are both returning and Salma
Hayek is also coming back as the titular
wife according to The Hollywood Reporter
the plot will find Reynolds bodyguard
trying to live a peaceful life when he
gets mixed up with Jackson's hitman once
more along with Hayek the trio will
apparently wreak havoc along the Amalfi
Coast in an attempt to save Europe from
some as yet unconfirmed threat the movie
will also star familiar names like
Morgan Freeman Antonio Banderas Frank
Grillo and Richard E grant if you're
hoping for a wild time at the movies
then this is the one for you insiders
are describing this film as the good the
bad and the bat-crazy according to
Deadline Robocop is indeed returning to
the big screen sometime soon although it
seems this new film is going to mess
around with the franchise's continuity
the original Robocop was directed by
Paul Verhoeven
and it made quite a killing when it was
released in 1987 after two sequels
during original actor Peter Weller the
franchise was rebooted in 2014 with
actor Joel Kinnaman and director jose
padilla the remake wasn't nearly as
popular as the first film and sadly for
mr. Kinnaman it looks like the new movie
is going to ignore the recent remake
altogether the latest entry in the
franchise will be called Robocop Returns
and is written by ad Neumayer and
Michael miner the guys who penned the
first film in fact a Robocop Returns was
apparently written right after the
original was released
sadly the script never got made into a
movie but now MGM is giving it another
go
with the help of some rewrites by
Terminator dark fate writer Justin
Rhodes
sadly Peter Weller won't be returning to
reprise his Robo role as for the plot
synopsis deadline writes in our key
rains and the fate of Detroit hangs in
balance as Robocop makes his triumphant
return to fight crime and corruption
though district nines Neill Blomkamp was
initially attached to direct he
announced in August 2019 that scheduling
conflicts had forced him to depart the
project in November 20 1901 Pictures
announced that little monsters director
a Forsyth had taken up the helm of
Robocop Returns and would also be giving
the screenplay a fresh rewrite your move
great what do you get when you cross a
horde of hungry zombies with a very fast
train a critically acclaimed blockbuster
that desperately needs a sequel
apparently released in 2016 train to
Busan earned 85 million dollars in its
homeland of South Korea and wowed
critics across the globe the plot
follows a selfish businessman who's
taking his daughter on a train ride to
the city of Busan when zombies suddenly
start popping up all over the place at
first the protagonist is only concerned
with protecting himself and his kid but
as things get bloodier and bloodier he
starts helping the other passengers
escape the oncoming horde now it seems
writer-director jung sang ho is working
on part two supposedly titled bando the
english title is being reported to be
peninsula which seems to imply that the
zombie virus has spread across Korea
shooting began in the summer of 2019
with a new cast stepping in front of the
camera it's evidently a good time to be
in the zombie train business as new line
is currently working on an American
remake of the first film of course if
you're new to the whole train to Busan
phenomenon you can prepare for both the
sequel and the reboot by checking out
the 2016 thriller in all its bloody
glory over on Netflix Sylvester Stallone
and the Expendables 4 have been engaging
in a will they won't they dance for a
few years now but the latest signs seem
to point definitively to they will
taking to his own Instagram account
Stallone announced in july 2019 that the
sequel was back on with a photo of the
star and his Expendables gear and the
caption all of those July 4th fireworks
got my mind going I'm starting to cook
up the next adventure
Stallone directed co-wrote and starred
in the original Expendables which came
out in 2010 he also helped write the
existing two sequels although for those
he handed off to wrecked oriole duties
to Simon West for two and Patrick Hughes
for three he walked away from the
Expendables 4 back in 2017
but his exit appears to have been only
temporary in addition to Stallone The
Expendables franchise has been a
veritable who's who of current and
former action superstars but only Jason
Statham and Arnold Schwarzenegger have
been confirmed as joining Stallone in
the Expendables 4 if and when Stallone
does finalize the fourth installment in
the series though you can expect the
cast list to grow exponentially with an
even more impressive collection of stars
than the previous three films after the
runaway success of The Hunger Games
series of books and films it seems
likely that audiences would one day
return to the dystopian world of Panem
one way or another and sure enough in
June 2019 publisher scholastic announced
that it would be releasing another novel
by Suzanne Collins set in The Hunger
Games world this book would be a prequel
set 64 years before the events of the
original story and would focus on the
10th Hunger Games in October 2019 the
book's title was revealed The Ballad of
songbirds and snakes along with the
announcement of the novel came the
confirmation that Collins prequel will
also receive the movie treatment
Lionsgate chairman Joe Drake who studio
adapted the Hunger Games films said of
the book announcement as the proud home
of the Hunger Games Movies we can hardly
wait for Suzanne's next book to be
published we've been communicating with
her during the writing process and we
look forward to continuing to work
closely with her on the movie The Ballad
of songbirds and snakes is scheduled to
hit bookshelves on May 19 2020 and from
the sounds of things war news about the
film adaptation will be right on its
heels directed by the one and only John
Carpenter Big Trouble in Little China is
one of the wackiest action movies ever
made this 1986 fantasy adventure follows
trucker Jack Burton as he attempts to
save a kidnapped woman from the dark and
magical underbelly of San Francisco's
Chinatown with its mortal kombat style
warriors and magical sword fights Big
Trouble in Little China has become a
beloved classic so naturally people were
a bit worried when a remake with Dwayne
Johnson was announced in 2015 there
hasn't been a lot of new info since then
but it's now clear that the new big
trouble will actually be a sequel
speaking to Collider producer Hyrum
Garcia
you can't remake a classic like big
trouble so what we're planning to do is
continue the story we're going to
continue the universe of Big Trouble in
Little China as Garcia went on to
explain the events of the first film
will still exist in the new Dwayne
Johnson movie on top of that the rock
will be playing a brand-new character
rather than Jack Burton so it seems
they're taking a page from the Jurassic
world playbook by crafting a movie that
exists and a pre-established timeline
but also serves as a kind of reboot for
a new generation
unfortunately Kurt Russell has told USA
Today that he probably won't be in the
sequel so Burton himself sadly won't be
back in the action for this one nobody
messes with the Jesus except for John
Turturro that is after all - Turo played
the purple clad Jesus in The Big
Lebowski and even though he's only on
screen for two scenes the pervy Boulder
apparently made enough of an impression
to war in his own spin-off movie once
called going places it's now known as
the Jesus rules and it has absolutely
nothing to do with the dude yeah well
you know that's just like your opinion
man the plot follows Jesus who's just
been released from jail after he was
framed for a crime he didn't commit
now a free man he teams up with two
friends and goes on a wild road trip
according to the film's official plot
synopsis the movie is a film about a
trio of misfits whose irreverent
sexually-charged - dynamic evolves into
a surprising love story as they're
spontaneous and flippant attitude
towards the past or future backfires
time and again even as they
inadvertently perform good deeds in
September 2019 a trailer for the Jesus
rolls appeared albeit one dubbed an
Italian to promote the film's release in
Italy as for the dynamic directing duo
the Cohens aren't involved with this
spin-off sequel but they're still
totally cool with Totoro making a part -
almost two decades after the first face
jam mashed up live-action comedy Looney
Tunes animation and professional
basketball Warner Brothers announced in
early 2014 but they'd be making a follow
up to the 1996 film the original Space
Jam starred NBA superstar Michael Jordan
and featured appearances from a number
of other NBA players alongside its
animated cast the sequel will star NBA
MVP LeBron James
addition to don cheadle fresh off his
almost decade-long stint in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe with a production
team that includes Black Panthers Ryan
Coogler
and The Fast and the Furious series
Justin Lin Space Jam 2 will be helmed by
director Malcolm D Lee Lee wasn't the
first director attached to the film
though he stepped in for Terrence Nance
who departed the production on good
terms in july 2019 citing creative
differences the film is set to hit
theaters on July 16 2021 almost a full
quarter of a century after the first
film premiered check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite movies
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]